hello and welcome to this video playing
Alonso mostly again get a pretty bad
game against him just a couple of home
videos ago when ya when I lost her had a
lost position but one on time you know
the Kings in yet I think it was yeah
some Kings Indian so trying something
different here hmm now on with the night
now let's take with the noid make it
more difficult for white to play them
with a for ya twin b6 was my intended to
move but I now see that there should be
three could be awkward so let's just go
a six of course one problem here I have
got very bad development
now I don't want to take and give them
the opportunity to play a phone again
night on 84 is an interesting placement
it's not that bad it's one of those
cases where night on the room is not so
damn because it looks at the beach when
see three pawns so and put some pressure
on white on white queen side seagoing 44
here maybe I probably should move the
Queen somewhere on this side
okay we're just Lucy eight
yeah probably h6 in one of the next most
get this Bishop way them yeah white has
one problem he has got no palm play
whatsoever c4 is I mean b3 and ce4 looks
like a complete illusion and deform yeah
you can take f6 and play you for but
that can never be good
he's running out of ideas I guess yeah
going back shooting for some kind of
fall I guess but ok and it's possibly
play anyway threatening Bishop t4 and
you can probably guess that I like to
have the payoff bishops um what now I
key I can just push in the center
already like a five not sure about it
but it looks looks good gain more space
and you for I am right
okay not sure about you for you might be
up 44 so let's do it it gives him the g4
square but I gained enormous space and
it also makes sure that this Bishop on
g2 is doing not much
okay I cannot go Bishop c8 that's a
that's a shame and for okay
so let's come back here 933 also nice
now I'm threaded in g 60 Jake's ok ok
maybe h5 and then g6 cupcakes sg6
well okay so let's go here okay he might
have knight c6 but it's not a big deal I
think at least no it's not man maybe it
is maybe it is I have not really come on
not well not really knight c6 27 is just
good or 26 yeah now I see I saw that but
if you look at this position now with
the night coming to the three years as a
disaster for white I mean okay can can
sacrifice something but ok I can also
look at the edge pawn so let's see and
it's not so easy though as d 5 is under
such pressure
hmm nah I played that badly amazing
amazing
check check g3 know that looks very
dangerous now just a mostly time warning
check so what now check can I get to his
kingdom check there Queenie to how does
it look like it
check tweenage to mate okay
check check check check check check Oh
check he's immensely slow and offered
quite for fence on time yeah I mean yeah
can I do yeah again he says again yeah
we had the same scenario in the earlier
game you have a TM I really felt like I
mean I was at a completely winning
position here so I felt they had someone
I just love to draw that same yeah just
this is winning the game not allowing
the loss of the exchange my positional
advantage she is just too too great
probably there was something something
he has founded yeah yeah it's got too
much pressure there I have to do this
and until I'm okay but of course not not
better and there was much better deform
can't get here shall also win but
somehow I didn't why am I not winning
chan that's champion here I can just
take the seven of course I how stupid I
just said I just felt like keep the
rukon enter and do stuff check yeah I
just wins the game
check yeah he had made ammonium made in
one queen age to mate so can dodging
bullets guarantee mi1 on time yeah well
okay thanks for watching